he is Tom Curren calm Kent are NBC
Sports Boston and covering the Patriots
there good morning tom hey Dan what are
you doing oh just curious about the
Patriots losing their coordinators
offensive and defensive coordinators saw
some of your tweets last night is it a
foregone conclusion you're losing both
Matt Patricia and Josh McDaniels unless
something absolutely bizarro happens
yeah they're both gone and I think it's
time in a lot of ways and I understand
why they would go to is it Tyler that
dangling in case you wanted to ask yeah
but it feels like Matt Patricia is more
valuable of the two coordinators or am i
reading more into that I think you're
reading more into it I think that both
of them that's part of the reason it's
time there's a kid Brian Flores who's
their linebackers coach who is behind
for sure he's the defensive coordinator
and waiting he'll most likely ascend
he's very promising young guy Arizona
actually had him out for an interview as
a head coaching candidate and then Chad
O'Shea would come up and replace
McDaniels and I think josh has has
passed on so many interviews and
opportunities over the years that I
think with Tom Brady at 40 it's probably
a good idea to go ahead and see
something else because if you look at
this team and the depth of it and aside
from the quarterback on the tight end
there's a lot of duct tape and you know
why are holding this team together at
this point
so um if I'm a guy who's hoping for a
head coaching job I go after were 13 and
3 and don't wait to go ten and six all
right
so Patricia to the Lions josh mcdaniels
to the Colts are you curious about did
Patricia turn down the Giants and are
you curious or surprised that McDaniels
would want to go into that cold
situation what I understand about Josh
in the cold situation he feels so
comfortable with Chris Ballard that that
was the place that he kind of wanted to
be all along and that's even with Andrew
Luck notwithstanding I know that Jim
Irsay is obviously a wild card to end
all wild cards but McDaniels
we should ship with Ballard is such that
they're gonna be able to share a vision
and that's important because when he was
in Denver you know the second he got
there he had so much support from Pat
Bowlen but you can't ibly he was
starting to deal with the early stages
of Alzheimer's and dementia and he was
forgetting conversations that he had had
and that really is what led to the
problem with Jay Cutler and once that
went south then there were other
machinations and Palace intrigues and
and you know involved itself here I
think he feels comfortable in that
ballard and he share a vision
Pyrus patricia i don't know how close
they got with the giants that felt odd
to me that he suddenly emerged as their
leading candidate it seemed like a
stretch was there any surprise with how
the Patriots played considering all the
so called drama off the field and would
that have an adverse effect I mean we
shouldn't be surprised at this but but
did you see anything that would be
curious or alarming with what you saw no
I didn't I think won't be interesting
going forward is now that these guys are
committed to go Dan all of these coaches
always take with them a few lieutenants
whether it's locker room lieutenants or
coaching staff lieutenants or support
staff lieutenants and with both of these
guys going someplace else I think
obviously Bill Belichick will have had a
conversation look I don't want to
breathe in the cupboard here I'd like to
see some of my coaches and staff stick
around because that's what led to an
issue with Eric Mangini in 2006 when
Mangini went to the Jets he basically
was walking around saying hey you know
where I'll be do you want to come along
and that's what led to their ugly
divorce he's Tom Curren NBC Sports
Boston joining us Dan Patrick show I we
know Tom Coughlin had the blueprint to
beat the Patriots a couple of times when
he was they had coach of the Giants now
that he's in the front office with
Jacksonville
looking at Jacksonville's roster does
Jacksonville have the opportunity to put
that same blueprint into play this
weekend absolutely they have a defense
that if the Patriots if they if
Jacksonville please fundamentally well
it doesn't get
all overhyped and trying to play the
tough of the now hard-ass game that they
did with the Steelers they'll be fine
and they can compete on the outside they
they do things that the Patriots have
problems with they have coleus Campbell
who's a house he'll be able to get up
upfield they'll be able to cover the
outside receivers because they have
corners that are better than the outside
receivers so then it'll come down to
holding down Grunk and you could even
send Jalen Ramsey across but the problem
I think defensively for them is as we
saw the Pittsburgh game they lost their
discipline because the game went along
and they were on so the way they rush
leaves alleys and leaves gaps so the
Patriots will probably be able to take
advantage that at some point it might
happen later rather than sooner but then
offensively the Patriots I mean you
can't in 2018 you can't just say we're
gonna try and run the ball it doesn't
work you have to throw it a little bit
and the Patriots are too good to let
them beat them offensively I think so if
they get over 17 points I'll be stunned
level of confidence in New England is
one in the region of New England
Patriots country oh I didn't know if you
met my level of positive I'll start with
that how is your level of confidence
tone generally high but I do think that
she actually take a chunk out of the
Patriots defensively I mean they made
Ben Roethlisberger look legitimately
scared the other day and they scored
just with him throwing punts that people
ran under so that said I think the
Patriots don't generally do that so it
I'm not seeing 42 points this week
however I think the overall feeling here
is boy I wonder how cold it'll be in
Minneapolis do I do you think I need
this to go if we're going to be in the
Twin Cities would you bet a toe against
a hundred grand but the Patriots are
going to the Superbowl
oh yeah any toe of your choice yeah but
only one a hundred thousand a hundred
thousand is not enough money okay you're
not that confident are you told
confident that's really what it comes
down to and you can ask Brady this hey
Tom are you told confident I would give
up the top half of my right ear I would
set the top half of my right here I'm
looking at those ears you've got a lot
to give up there what if I you have to
give up the top of your ear with Tyson
taking the top of your ear for a hundred
grand yeah afterwards you can imagine
the spittle that would be all over I'm
gonna let Brady's doctor is a health
guru he's gonna do it he doesn't do a
mutation
[Laughter]
hey all right I'll see you in
Minneapolis yeah you will this will be
fun I still have all the stuff you
haven't gave us last week you bring it
last year you bringing stuff to share -
yeah yeah absolutely good I'll hang on
honey here on the set are you going if
the Patriots don't go Dan I'm gonna go
irregardless okay all right that's good
all right well then all I'll see you
there in Minneapolis okay all right
that's Tom Curren NBC Sports Boston he's
a knucklehead for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
you